feel reluctant to even Venture there but
uh he did play a massive massive spoiler
role there and Peter there we have it
there it is
handshake and congratulations to Anish
Gary 2023 how to steal champion
there we go Anish he's finally done it
yes
he won the second Super tournament in
his life the first one obviously being
the the Mr dodgy Invitational he won
a few years back he's won two of those
Peter yeah I'm trying to Black I I'm
trying to blank that memory out because
think uh at least in one of them I lost
to him somewhere along the way and that
was too painful for words of
but yeah yeah he's got that monkey off
his back now no you can make jokes about
not winning the Super tournaments I
think Reggio Emilio was the previous one
in 2011. yeah uh so he won he won a very
very strong round robin in uh in in
China but people who want to nitpick try
to pretend that it wasn't sort of it was
she just wasn't strong enough for
well that particular qualification but
yeah